I'm Alex and this is a game spot news
update following several recent
controversies interim CEO of Reddit
Ellen Pao has stepped down from her
position she will be replaced by reddit
founder and original CEO Steve Huffman
in a post on reddit board member Sam
Altman explained that POW was resigning
following a mutual agreement with the
board of directors the board has chosen
Huffman as the next head of Reddit he
said we're very happy to have Steve back
product and community are the two legs
of Reddit and the board was very focused
on finding a candidate who excels at
both which Steve does he has the added
bonus of being a founder with ten years
about it history in his head how's
resignation follows two decisions that
sparked outrage among the websites
community in June the red administration
ban five subreddits for offensive
material then the website fired a
popular admin who helped coordinate ask
me anything threads with famous
scientists actors and other celebrities
both of these decisions caused
widespread anger among the community and
a change.org petition calling for paused
resignation has accumulated over 200,000
signatures Steve Huffman the new CEO has
promised several improvements to reddit
including more moderation tools and a
better mobile site what do you think of
the changes let us know in the comments
below and for more news keep an eye on
gamespot com
you